all right so this is a paper Pete and I
was expecting that watching this the
whole time this is kind of like and okay
yeah you know you're kind of in a bad
spot when you rather be reading the book
that Jake is reading the battery other
rainicorns I am Rana topi or whatever is
called a rainbow cornucopia yeah I was
just like oh my god this episode's gonna
be awesome
oh no this is and it's okay so Jake
wants to read up on Reina Corbett Tokyo
whatever it's called you know so
Rainicorn had pop wings you know pop
wings or whatever they're called um
Reina puppies I don't know um how would
they even I don't know I'll remember he
can stretch we've already had this yeah
yeah okay um so fan goes and finds
they're these little local paper Ling's
was that yes uh Paisley Paisley that was
that your barracks for the him with
paper Pete yeah home EPP yes but he
calls and Pete and that I love the idea
that the they are the opening and
closing pages to each book egg so they
protect it from being eaten by these
other creatures or just anything bag
that's really funny I think that's
really creative
um and even their design is kind of cool
they're just like folded little you know
paper creatures or was it already
origami yeah um have you ever been
origamis yes awesome
oh it's the adventures of the gummi
bears huh yes like the Disney show they
had origamis in an episode yes really
yes that's one of the later ones that's
really funny
yeah good jokerman good good job Disney
Oh better than the jokes in this episode
let me tell you why I'm being so really
needlessly mean honestly this is like a
perfectly passive
episode four like just kids in general
humor and stuff like that it's like ah
see if you just put this show on I said
okay fine whatever ideas kind of a
clever setup and where these little slug
people are actually trying to eat the
pages which is funny and then they have
to sort of fight them off while
convincing Jade that they exist and you
know it's it's fine it's just again just
compared to all their other stuff all
the other Adventure Time stuff it's just
sort of like and I guess I want those
people I really don't like I love the
few people in the world huge Chuck Jones
fan I me adore I mean I just love it
almost everything he does I was never a
big fan of the singing frog I just that
kind of story drives me nuts when it's
the just look over here and then they
disappear that's like no no come and see
this time and then they're not doing it
stuff always gets in the way it just
drives me nuts which is not to say
there's some that's my stuff and singing
frogs but I just can't stand those
stories it's like we were talking about
before when somebody's framed or
somebody can't tell somebody something
or they're doing against their will or
yeah those cave episodes just drives me
nuts because you know what's gonna
happen you know the truth and it's just
more frustrating than funny and I know
that's like the idea well the
frustration is the humor but to me it's
just frustrating so um and yeah there's
it just takes place and kind of a boring
library and he just serve walks it
Oh boring whatever are you compared to
an exciting one where they're sale on
avatar is pretty cool actually I just
read an actual library technically yes
no it's not by a gigantic owl but eats
people I don't I don't trust you it you
should see the show no my friend no or
just watch my view logs it's just as
exciting then it's not true just watch
it like what I want you I know it's bad
enough you sit next we don't laugh at
that people watch me sometimes when I'm
asleep I do all the time oh you too
thank you I told you that already I
imagine I agree to hear it again just
makes me feel loved I was like I like
this episode I don't care what you say
yeah yeah hey what do you think about
hey honestly for me it kind of brings me
back to my childhood with big bird and
snuffleupagus cuz I can't wait to hear
back well no in the beginning everyone
didn't believe snuffleupagus existed he
was big birds imaginary friends and
anytime that they wanted to anytime Big
Bird wanted to say hey look Khmer look
at Snug look at my friend Snuffy Snuffy
would always be gone so for a long time
everyone always kind of just thought
that snuffleupagus was a figment of big
of big birds imagination isn't he I
thought best known as does Oh after a
while it turned out and this is like
after years it turned out that stuff he
was actually real what the toys to me
what the twist so for me it was kind of
more along those lines where Finn didn't
care about this fighting that was going
on he didn't care about saving the books
he didn't care about anything he just
wanted to prove to his friend that he's
not making up these adventures and that
these things aren't a figment of his
imagination to the point of even hurting
his friend and no big bird never hurt
you just takes Cromer and starts hitting
him into the garbage can no I mean that
was your kid be in there like all diga
snack and touching it's just too funny
but Vinnie has to be Street massacre
pin is just so concerned with saying no
I'm not making this up that he goes as
far as actually hurting Jake he's like
oh it hurts like it stings like the
dickens perfect I got a great idea he
could have ended the war between the two
and stuff - lets up Lahaina did but yeah
he's doing it more just Jake I mean so
it was kind of like the whole imagine
ancient thing where every time he got
close they happened to turn or fall off
one way or do something the other way
and it just made me think back to Big
Bird snuffleupagus well ok I'm just
being burned and snuffleupagus thing is
cool but
I was also a kid okay let's just say my
kids okay but does that make this good
it just remind you something I like the
whole musical frog thing I've never seen
that X you've never seen it I mean it's
a lie if you like this you'll really
like singing fry I mean awesome okay
because this is oh it's dark really it
well yeah no it's actually pretty dark
well it's a good idea it's one of the
first it's one of the first things to
ever do this idea I mean everyone sir
compares sir calls this the singing frog
you know story um that's the hello my
baby hello my honey yeah okay I want to
live from Spaceballs yeah no it's
actually pretty it's actually pretty
dark what I think about really it see to
me it's just frustrating it's I love I
mean it's it's another it's another
thing to talk about in our time because
you you can't technically talk about a
lot of people say it's like this isn't a
- Warner Brothers cartoons and stuff
like that and it's just sitting Coombes
okay it's not there's a lot of people
that don't like that either is fine
okay well bottom line it's and I guess
in a way it kind of isn't that it
started this kind of joke this kind of
story of leave this incredible thing but
then when somebody looks it's not doing
it gotcha oh wait oh wait is that the
one where did some frog sings and he
tries to grab his friend shows to him
says look he's singing in the problems
like ribbit yeah okay I have seen that
nevermind I'm wrong yeah and it pretty
much ruins his life and the flakes are
thrown away or someone else finds it
girls who all make millions it's like
it's a good setup it's a good story it's
just it frustrates the hell out of me
so I guess I guess I can see how someone
can like it it yeah just in did grab me
too much understand so yes there it is
paper Pete one of the most memorable
iconic characters of all time
pee pee pee pee we're gonna end on pee
pee
I can't ask for anything